distinguished guests dear Mayors and
representatives of local authorities
ladies and gentlemen
Europe is a land of amazing cities
places with a strong character
that you can feel at every corner and in
every Square
but also places where everyone feels at
home
I want Europe to be like its cities
a union where it doesn't matter what you
look like who you love how you pray and
where you were born
a union of equality where everyone
enjoys the same rights and feels welcome
at home
in these three years the European
commission has launched a new push for
equal rights across our Union
new initiatives Against Racism
and to Foster minority rights
strategies for lgbtiq equality
and the rights of persons with
disabilities
and the renovation wave to make our
cities not just greener
but more accessible to all
we've done all this because this is what
millions of Europeans demand
and in fact we see countless regions
cities and towns across Europe that are
moving in the same direction
you are closest to citizens
you are closest
to the aspirations
your cities and regions are the engine
of change in our continent the place
where identity meets inclusion
and this is why we decided to create
these Awards for European capitals of
inclusion and diversity
today we will hear stories from all
corners of our Union from Portugal to
Poland from big cities to small towns
it is proof that this journey towards
great equality unites us
Beyond geography
Beyond social background
Beyond political affiliation
your stories can be an inspiration for
millions of Europeans
and positive change is happening across
our Union because you are making it
happen
this is why we have decided to put the
spotlight on you
on your inclusivity
your Innovations your ingenuity
you are making everyone feel that they
belong in your cities and regions
so you are showing the best of Europe
and today Europe celebrates you
so congratulations to the winners
and welcome to the European capitals of
inclusion and diversity Awards